Across the Universe an endless war rages
a bitter struggle
between invisible forces
dark matter
and dark energy
battling for control of the universe
we've seen this Cosmic battle go on for
the past 14 billion years
like two Davies biting it out in the
ocean of space-time shadowy forces
dictating our past our present and our
future the Dark Universe is kind of a
puppet master behind the scenes guiding
the universe that we can see it's taken
over the universe and eventually it may
well destroy the universe
as we look out Across the Universe
we see nebulas
Stars
and planets
all constructed from visible matter
but what we see is just a small part of
the cosmos
the rest is invisible unknown
Dark Universe
Dark Universe is a very common phrase to
describe our universe because it turns
out most of our Cosmos is dark
dark not as in night dark as in doesn't
interact with light and dark as in we
don't really understand it
[Music]
the Dark Universe is made of two forces
dark matter
and dark energy
in a way the dark matter and dark energy
sort of oppose each other
dark matter has positive gravity it
pulls things together and dark energy
has repulsive gravity that pushes things
apart
dark matter and dark energy are locked
in this epic struggle the dark matter is
trying to bring things together
the dark energy is trying to drive
everything apart all the objects in our
daily experience our bodies the air the
chair that you're sitting in
the planets and stars all of that only
adds up to five percent of the universe
it's the other 95 percent that is the
dark stuff the Dark Universe
to encapsulate that in one sentence dark
matter is attractive dark energy is
repulsive
since the dawn of time two forces
slugging it out for control of the
universe
it's a struggle that started 13.8
billion years ago
in the cosmic furnace of the Big Bang
the infant Universe was a super hot ball
of intense radiation but suddenly
started to transform
Ed and expanded
triggering the birth of the regular
universe
and the Dark Universe
scientists believe that both dark matter
and dark energy formed in the first
moments of the Big Bang it would have
formed probably just fractions of a
second after the big bang around the
time that normal matter formed and the
processes that created the normal matter
we know all about similar processes
probably created the dark matter
during these first microseconds the
universe was a hot dense ball of matter
and energy
there are two sides of the same coin
matter can convert into energy
and energy can convert directly into
matter
visible particles of regular matter
forming atoms planets stars and us
and other particles they are invisible
they are dark matter one of the big
Mysteries that we as astronomers have to
solve is what this dark matter is we
just don't know
the idea of a type of matter that you
can't see and that acts differently than
normal matter is sort of out there it's
sort of weird
it's like a crime scene you know that a
crime has been committed even though you
don't know the perpetrator yet we see
the hints we see the signs we see the
signals that something funny is
happening in our universe even though we
don't know exactly what's causing it
there are several contenders for what
Dark Matter could be
could be normal matter that we just
don't see or it could be some sort of
exotic matter a particle of some sort
that we haven't detected yet it could be
a species of particle like an electron
like a proton like a quark but a special
kind that doesn't interact with light
dark energy has existed since the time
of the Big Bang Dark Energy was always
there we don't know how much of it there
was but it's possible that the same
amount of dark energy was always there
dark energy is nothing more than a
placeholder name for this enormous Gap
in our understanding of how the cosmos
works but we don't understand it at all
that's true
one potential answer to what Dark Energy
actually is may be found in so-called
empty space
could this be the source of dark energy
we used to think of space it's just
boring emptiness but now
I think it's healthier to think of space
as a kind of substance
a substance that carries a strange type
of energy every small region of space
has a little bit of energy in it just
associated with the vacuum itself
vacuum energy is the idea that
vacuum isn't empty that there's
something there there's an energy in it
with a kind of anti-gravity
perhaps this vacuum energy that pushes
Against Gravity
is the mysterious dark energy
we simply don't know
we're not sure that the dark energy is
the vacuum energy
it could be a new type of energy that
permeates all of space this is what
we're trying to measure now
dark energy and dark matter forged in
the intense heat of the Big Bang
opposing forces one attractive one
repulsive but together over 13.8 billion
years they will shape the history of the
universe
as the cosmic web evolves into a more
complex structure
gaps form between the filaments the
cosmic voids
the cosmic voids formed because other
more dense regions of the universe
gravitationally stole material away from
them so the dense parts of the universe
accumulated more matter at the expense
of the less dense Parts which then
became voids dark energy
played no role it was insignificant
but at some stage in the 14 billion
years since the big bang these roles
became reversed
Dark Energy came to be the more powerful
force
the question was when
the answer came at the end of the 20th
century
the beginning of the universe shaping it
and actually creating the conditions for
us to be here and it's taken over the
universe and eventually it may well
destroy the universe
our universe may be dominated by the
long struggle between dark matter and
dark energy
but all of this conflict has led to a
creative outcome an outcome for which we
should all be grateful